über 20.000 bekennende Reichsbürger soll
es in Deutschland geben 10% davon laut
Sicherheitsbehörden gewaltbereiten mit
umstutzplänen im Gepäck und
offensichtlich überaus gut vernetzt eine
Razzia hat es in den Tag gebracht
hunderte sogenannter Heimatschutz
Kompanien waren geplant die politische
Führung des Landes sollte festgesetzt
möglicherweise getötet werden auch
Finanzmittel in Millionenhöhe wurden
offensichtlich bei den Durchsuchungen
gefunden gerade in Sicherheitsbehörden
soll es zahlreiche Unterstützer dieser
Reichsbürger geben
viel Arbeit für den Generalbundesanwalt
und später die Gerichte
nach reichsbürgerratia wie muss der
Staat sich wehren jetzt in der
phoenix-runde
[Musik]
herzlich Willkommen bei uns meine Gäste
die im Studio Sebastian Fiedler ist bei
uns sie sitzen für die SPD im Bundestag
sind dort mitgegeben rechts und im
Innenausschuss und kriminalpolitischer
Sprecher ihrer Fraktion kurztrifft kurio
ist ebenfalls mit dem Innenausschuss
innenpolitischer Sprecher der
afd-fraktion im Bundestag in politischer
Sprecher ist auch Alexander Turm von der
CDU CSU-Fraktion sie sind auch mit dem
Innenausschuss wichtig weil gestern dort
im Innen und den Rechtsausschuss zum
Thema wichtige Sitzungen waren
schließlich meine Kolleginnen evakubeck
leitet das hauptstadtbüro des
redaktionsnetzwerks Deutschland einen
Zusammenschluss verschiedener
Tageszeitung Herr Fiedler der größte
Anti terror-einsatz in der Geschichte
der Bundesrepublik gewesen sein hat sie
das Ausmaß der dabei bislang gewonnenen
Erkenntnisse überrascht
also erstmal hat mich der gesamte das
Ausmaß des Einsatzes überrascht weil das
glaube ich so also ist keine triviale
Herausforderung für die
Sicherheitsbehörden über einen langen
Zeitraum so viele Maßnahmen umzusetzen
hunderte von
Gerichtsbeschlüssen tatsächlich auch
umzusetzen und das dann ganz das ganze
auf die auf die Beine zu stellen ist
erstmal eine Riesenleistung gewesen und
das Ausmaß was zu Tage befördert worden
ist da sehen wir ja bisher ersten
Ausschnitt also man muss deutlich machen
die Ermittlungsbehörden fangen ja jetzt
erstmal richtig an noch mit den weiteren
Ermittlungen aber es liefert einen
Ausschnitt einer Terrororganisation die
sich offensichtlich hier auf dem Boden
verschwörerischer rechtsextremer
Ideologien gegründet hat und ähm das
wird uns auch in den nächsten Monaten
und Jahren glaube ich noch weiter
beschäftigen müssen
zugleich ist ja das unter den
Verdächtigen die jetzt festgenommen
worden sind ehemalige Soldaten
Polizisten und eine Richterin sind die
ja gerade diese Personen sollen ja
unsere Demokratie schützen Kollegen die
sogar einen Eid ab unter diesen
Umständen wie sieht es mit unserer
Sicherheit hier im Land aus also da will
ich zunächst mal sagen dass es eine sehr
kleiner Ausschnitt ist derer die da
jetzt beschuldigt werden grundsätzlich
können wir unseren Sicherheitsbehörden
unseren Beamtinnen und Beamten vertrauen
die ganz ganz große Mehrheit dieser
beamtinnenbeamten machen einen guten
Dienst für unseren Staat und für unseren
Rechtsstaat und für die Demokratie aber
klar ist wir müssen von allen und zwar
ausnahmslos erwarten dass sie auf dem
Boden unserer demokratischen
Grundordnung stehen und wir erwarten da
auch gerade eine ganz besondere
Festigkeit gegenüber derartigen
ideologischen Anfeindungen
extremistische Art ähm ihre beiden
Parteien Fraktionsvorsitzenden alles
weitere Kinder haben gesagt sie hätten
vollstes Vertrauen in die ermittelnden
oder die beteiligten Behörden immerhin
gehört ja auch eine E Fraktionskollegin
von ihnen zu den Festgenommenen haben
sie auch dieses vollste Vertrauen
ja ich habe keinen Grund es nicht zu
haben und es ist ja eine gute Sache dass
hier offenbar bevorstehende Straftaten
verhindert worden sind durch den Einsatz
und das der Staat insofern auch
funktioniert gegenüber Personen die
unsere staatliche Ordnung angreifen
wollen ist erstmal eine gute Nachricht
an für sich
sind denn die sogenannten Reichsbürger
in ihrer Gefährlichkeit bisher
unterschätzt worden dieses
narrativ dass sie da verbreiten oder die
narrative die mutiert ziemlich weltfremd
an auf den ersten Blick wie sieht es da
auf den zweiten Blick aus naja also der
Verfassungsschutz hat die Reichsbürger
ja schon länger auf dem Schirm und auch
die Idee legitimierer des Staates sind
eine neue Gruppe geworden von
verfassungsvereinten die eben vom
Verfassungsschutz beobachtet werden also
von daher würde ich sagen nicht
unterschätzt man muss natürlich jetzt
aufpassen das was die machen wie die in
der Öffentlichkeit auftreten das was die
vor das ist für einen normalen
Demokraten natürlich total kurios und
verführt auch also so ein bisschen das
von der kabarettistischen Seite zu
betrachten darf man aber nicht tun weil
die sind ja festgenommen worden mit dem
Vorwurf eine terroristische Organisation
gründen zu wollen oder gegründet zu
haben und eben konkret Anschläge zu
planen bzw einen staatsumsturz und von
daher ist die Gefahr auf jeden Fall
inzwischen erkannt und der Kundige
tebaner konnte das auch vorher schon
wissen aus ihrer Fraktion kam ja auch
weil sie gesagt würden sie das hier so
eher kapitalistische Ansätze waren dass
das so etwas ja auch ins Lächerliche
gezogen worden ist was da passiert ist
in den letzten Tagen und bei der Razzia
nimmt die AFD das ernst was da passiert
ist wir nehmen das absolut ernst und ich
weiß jetzt nicht genau wirklich auf
welche Äußerung ist sich bezieht was ich
mir vielleicht denken könnte ist dass
die sehr
hohe Darlegung der Gefahr für den Staat
durch einen unmittelbar bevorstehenden
Staatsstreich
die hat sich vielleicht auch im Zuge der
gestrigen Sondersitzung so nicht
bestätigt jeder einzelne
Staatsfeind der vielleicht verrückte
Ansichten hat und der auch über Waffen
verfügt ist eine Gefahr ist einer zu
viel dennoch glaube ich dass ein
tatsächlich einen Gefahr für einen
wirklichen Umsturz des Staates hier zu
keiner Zeit bestand und wenn also da
diese sehr hohe Darstellung der Gefahr
ein klein wenig wieder ins faktische der
Realität heruntergeholt worden ist dann
sollte vielleicht nur das Bespielen
Realität runterholen indem man darauf
verweist weswegen die festgenommen
worden sind nämlich wegen Mitgliedschaft
in einer touristischen Vereinigung und
nicht wegen direkt unmittelbar
bevorstehenden Stadt streicht das ja
nichts was die Behörden behauptet haben
nein aber in der öffentlichen Debatte
glaube ich ist es fair zu sagen dass was
uns die letzten Tage seit vorigen
Mittwoch beschäftigt hat schon das
Stichwort ist ein Staatsstreiches
abgewendet worden wenn ich das mal ganz
grob zusammenfassen darf und das war
vielleicht die Intention dieser
Fantasten und kriminellen aber die
tatsächliche Hinterlegung personell und
waffentechnisch scheint dem nicht
wirklich
zur Frage etwas anders
gesagt hat weil das ist die
Relativierung äh
Verteidigungslinie die die AFD jetzt
seit einigen Tagen versucht zu betreiben
sie verkennt wesentliche Umstände ein
Umstand ist eben und das ist auch noch
mal gesagt worden im Inno dem
Rechtsausschuss es geht um die Bildung
und Unterstützung an der terroristischen
Vereinigung und da ist auch relevant
welche Tatbestandsmerkmale nämlich eine
Vereinigung deren Mitglieder bereit sind
zu töten das ist Gegenstand der Vorwürfe
darum geht es und jetzt wird die
Erzählung gebildet es angeblich darum
gegangen also nicht von mir sondern von
anderen unter anderem von der AFD ob
jetzt hier ein Staatsstreich abgewendet
werden konnte oder ob die Ziele diese
kruden Ziele die diese Organisation sich
gegeben hat hätten abgewendet werden
können das möchte ich mal uns bitten
vielleicht auch mal mit anderen
extremistischen und terroristischen
Organisationen zu vergleichen während
wir ernsthaft auf die Idee gekommen und
hätten eine Debatte über den Islamismus
geführt und hätten dann gesagt dass er
eine Kuh die Idee hier ein Gottesstaat
zu errichten hätten wir das so Anis Amri
gesagt niemand wäre auf diese Idee
gekommen also es geht hier nicht darum
sondern es geht darum es ist ein
Verbrechens Tatbestand in der
Generalbundesanwalt hier untersucht es
sind alle die Haftbefehle sind alle
bestätigt worden vom Bundesgerichtshof
also das heißt die Vorwürfe haben
offensichtlich auch gerichtlicher
Überprüfung standgehalten da gibt es
überhaupt keinen Momentum der
Relativierung sondern es handelt sich
ganz offenkundig um eine gefährliche
Organisation deren Mitglieder
offenkundig sich darüber ausgetauscht
haben unter anderem Menschen zu töten
für ihre Ziele hätte um was waren denn
das für Personen gibt es da Erkenntnisse
inzwischen
auf die die Reichsbürger zugegangen sind
die sogenannten Reichsbürger um sie zu
gewinnen zu rekrutieren wissen wir da
welche Leute sie da im Blick hatten es
würde ja von heimatschutzkompanie ich
habe schon zitiert gesprochen 280 Stück
jetzt die Frage ob das alles realistisch
ist ist das eine das andere auf welche
Menschen ist man dazu gegangen um sie
für die reichsbürgerideen zu gewinnen
also das ist eine ganz
toxische Mischung die da entstanden ist
bei den Personen Reichsbürger
q-n-anhänger
Verschwörungstheoretiker aller Art aber
auch Rechtsextreme und man darf das
nicht verharmlosen das ist aber das was
die AFD genau in den letzten Tagen
versucht an der Spitze ihre
Fraktionsvorsitzende Frau Weidel jetzt
schon Untersuchungsausschuss fordert
weil die die Sicherheitsbehörden
überzogen hätten und das alles aufgebaut
hätten und das zeigt dass es und das hat
man ja auch gesehen da schon auch eine
gewisse geistige Nähe zwischen der AFD
und derartigen Verschwörungstheoretikern
gibt es auch immer wieder in der
politischen
Argumentation in der politischen Arbeit
der AFD thematisiert wird und wo auf der
an der Boden gebildet wird wenn ich
darauf antworten darf das natürlich
Unsinn es gibt keine Relativierung ich
habe ja eingangs das Statement gemacht
dass selbstverständlich hier eine
kriminelle Vereinigung mit kriminellen
Zielen hoch mitgenommen wurde und dass
das richtig und gut ist und dass der
Staat da funktioniert hat eine ganz
andere Frage ist ob die von diesen
Personen angestrebten Zielen eines
tatsächlichen Umsturzes der staatlichen
Ordnung irgendwie in realistischer
Reichweite war und nur diesbezüglich ist
eine
Adjustierung der Erzählung hier
vorzunehmen denn zum Glück scheint das
nicht der Fall gewesen zu sein wenn wir
hören dass es nur eine zweistellige
Anzahl von tatsächlich jetzt in
Untersuchungshaft befindlichen Personen
gibt und nur eine zweistellige Anzahl
von Waffen die da vorhanden waren das
klingt erstmal nicht so als ob man damit
die Polizei Kräfte und die Bundeswehr
und die staatlichen Organe der Runde
Republik Deutschland bezwingen könnte
jede Waffe in der Hand eines verrückten
staatsfeindes ist eine zu viel aber man
muss schon auch diese dass die richtig
die größten Ordnung der
generalbundesamt bzw der Haftrichter
beim Bundesgerichtshof hat hier alle
bestätigt dass uns jetzt gerade auch
gesagt und einen Haftgrund für eine für
eine Untersuchungshaft liegt ja nur vor
wenn ein dringender Tatverdacht besteht
und wenn eine Verurteilung im
Hauptverfahren sehr wahrscheinlich ist
also so nach dem Motto da hat war ja
auch noch der Vorwurf der kam aus ihrer
Fraktion es wurde ab von diesem Mordfall
an dem jungen Mädchen in Illertissen da
gibt es aber doch eine eine gravierenden
Grund für den Haft Richter diese
Untersuchungshaft für 23 Personen für 22
Personen anzuordnen darum sage ich auch
da hat der Staat insoweit funktioniert
und das eine gute Sache noch mal
lediglich bei der Frage ob eine Katze
die Gefahr eine tatsächlich ein
Umsturzes des Staates hier im Raume
stand nur diesbezüglich haben wir die
Dinge ein wenig gerade zurück Rücken
angesichts hier also einer zweistelligen
Gruppe von Leuten eine zweistelligen
Menge von Waffen aber es ist tatsächlich
so dass wir gestern auch in der
Innenausschuss Sitzung erfahren habe
dass der oft in den letzten Tagen
diskutierte Vorwurf einer irgendwie
bevorstehenden Attacke auf den Bundestag
das der tatsächlich nicht für tragfähig
befunden wurde von dem
Untersuchungsrichter dass es etwas was
stark diskutiert wurde gerade auch im
Zusammenhang mit der ex-abgeordneten
inwieweit er Sicherheitsrisiken vorlegen
tatsächlich müssen ex-abgeordnete ganz
normal durch die Sicherheitsschleuse
also da gibt es eine gewisse Entspannung
niemand hat ja behauptet dass ein
Staatsstreich unmittelbar bevorsteht
sondern es ist gesagt worden dass diese
Leute die da festgenommen worden sind
ein Staatsstreich planen wollten dass
sie nicht dazu fähig sind die
demokratische Grundordnung die
Verfassung die Verfasstheit unserer
Republik außer Kraft zu setzen da steht
vollkommen außer Frage das behauptet
auch wirklich niemand aber man muss
schon zur Kenntnis nehmen dass eben die
ehemalige AFD Abgeordnete immer noch
freien Zugang zum Bundestag hat und
natürlich möglicherweise über alte
Kontakte durchaus Schaden hätte
anrichten können diese
möglichen Täter wären nicht besonders
weit gekommen aber großen Schaden hätten
sie natürlich schon einrichten anrichten
können wenn sie in irgendeiner Form mit
Waffen in das Reichstagsgebäude hätten
eindringen können nur das Wort freier
Zugang möchte ich kommentieren da ist es
so dass die Ex Abgeordneten eben sehr
wohl durch die Sicherheitsschleuse
müssen die haben also in der Beziehung
gerade keinen sicherheitsrelevanten
aber die können jederzeit in den
Bundestag gehen anders als andere
mögliche Straftäter durch die
Sicherheitsschleuse
sie haben von einer neuen Qualität
gesprochen bei dieser Terrorgruppe sie
nennen jetzt nicht mehr
rechtsextremistisch in verschiedenen
Formen oder ausformen sagen es handelt
sich eigentlich um einen
verschwörungsextremismus oder
verschwörungsterrorismus
die Zahl der Reichsbürger hat ja in der
letzten Zeit auch gerade werden der
corona-pandemie ja zugenommen warum
fühlt sich Menschen eigentlich von
solchen verschwörungsmythen oder
verschwörungs Theorien so angezogen ja
genau verschwörungsmythen das glaube ich
so die bessere Begrifflichkeit ich will
erstmal erklären warum ich diesen
Begriff nenne und dann auf den zweiten
Teil antworten weil wir eben feststellen
und das mit wir meine ich jetzt das
sagen uns auch die Sicherheitsbehörden
und der anderen die Nachrichtendienste
dass wir nicht mehr so klassisch
unterscheiden können und das hat sich
insbesondere in den Protesten gegen die
corona-maßnahmen sehr starke zeigt sie
können nicht mal separieren ob es in
Anführungszeichen klassische
rechtsextreme sind oder welchen
Gruppierungen sie sie zuordnen können
sondern das zeigt sich auch in diesem
Verfahren hier das mischen sich
unterschiedliche coole Ideologien und
jetzt ist es natürlich schwierig das mit
Begriffen zu fassen der
Verfassungsschutz hat eine wie ich finde
zwar zutreffend aber sehr sperrige
Begrifflichkeit gegen legitimierer also
Leute die den Staat in Grenze nicht die
legitimieren allerdings nicht nur den
Staat sondern auch die freie Presse ich
habe versucht sondern als verbindendes
Element verschwörerische Mythen im
Grunde zu identifizieren so scheint es
ja auch hier zu sein und deswegen glaube
ich müssen wir auf diesen neuen dieses
Konglomerat dann unterschiedlichen
extremistischen Strömungen hier auch
neue schauen und unter anderem
zusätzliche neue Antworten auf die von
ihnen aufgeworfene Frage stellen denn zu
Wahrheit gehört wir wissen noch nicht so
viel darüber wie wir zum Beispiel über
die Entstehung Radikalisierung im
Bereich Rechtsextremismus
Linksextremismus Islamismus wissen es
gibt noch sehr viele Fragen die zwar
teilweise auch im Ausland untersucht
worden sind aber wir sind da noch nicht
gleich gut aufgestellt das muss man
sagen also wir wissen noch nicht genau
wie eigentlich radikalisiert sich jemand
in welcher Geschwindigkeit er zufällig
ist es eher so eine Art wie der Spiegel
tituliert hatten mitmach Extremismus das
heißt es gibt Angebote im Netz und Leute
fühlen sich davon angezogen werden Sie
aktiv angesprochen oder nicht jedenfalls
muss man sagen und die Verbindung
sozusagen die haben wir noch nicht gut
genug glaube ich herausgearbeitet heute
kommt der AFD als rechtsextreme Kraft in
den Parlamenten hier eine überaus
bedeutende Rolle zu weil wir im Plenum
jedenfalls erproben mag das glaube ich
mag das Leid teilen mit mir ähnliche
Geschichten gehört haben dort während
der corona-pandemie haben wir ja
ebenfalls auch aus der afd-fraktion
verrückte Mythen gehört die erinnere
mich an eine Abgeordnete immer mit so
einem plastikschirm eine Ärztin wilde
Geschichten erzählt hat sich von der
Lauterbach erklären lassen musste wie
die Fakten tatsächlich sind also sie
finden an vielen vielen Stellen
verbindende Elemente zu den Mythen die
dort erzählt werden bei den Abgeordneten
der afd-fraktion wieder und sie ist ja
aus guten Gründen und das hat auch der
Präsident des Verfassungsschutzes jetzt
uns gestern noch mal sehr detailliert
gesagt eingestuft als rechtsextreme
Strömung und ich habe daran auch gar
keinen Zweifel der kurios Zitate selber
sind Gegenstand dieser Expertise
geworden die auch gerichtlicher
überprüft worden ist die dazu geführt
hat dass man sagt es gibt dort
rassistische Erzählungen es gibt dort
Erzählungen man wolle hier durch
Einwanderung von Muslimen sozusagen der
Staatsvolk austauschen das sind alles
Zitate die eingeflossen sind in die
Expertise und die Gutachten des
Verfassungsschutzes und deswegen gibt es
eine enge Verbindung der politischen
Ausrichtung der AFD zu diesen
verschwörungsextremisten das darf man
nicht relativieren denn es bildet den
Nährboden für Terrorismus der hier
entstanden ist nicht mehr und nicht
weniger sie haben ja immer gesagt der es
gibt keine Verbindung zwischen der AFD
und den reichsbürgern bevor ich jetzt in
diese Frage stelle Herr throm sehen Sie
das ähnlich oder sehen Sie es wie Herr
Fiedler das ist da doch ganz
offensichtliche Verbindungen geben
verschiedene ideologische Strömungen
zusammen die sich alle da zusammen
mischen Reichsbürger
Verschwörungstheoretiker einen Anhänger
staatsdelikidimierer in in ihrer Gänse
und das ist ja auch das was die AFD
immer wieder befeuert im Plenum wieder
Kollege Fiedler sagt aber auch außerhalb
des Plenums in den sozialen Medien
insbesondere und das bildet in der Tat
einen Nährboden für eine
zunehmende Abwendung von unserem Staat
jedenfalls in einer beträchtlichen
Gruppe in unserer Gesellschaft und das
ist das gefährliche eigentlich dass
dadurch entstanden ist die Gruppe die
jetzt letzte Woche ausgehoben wurde
ist ja da eigentlich nur die Spitze des
Eisbergs und deswegen ist die
Gefährlichkeit auch so gegeben auch die
Gefährlichkeit einzelner Personen aus
dieser Gruppe heraus und deswegen dürfen
wir es auch nicht verharmlosen und die
geistige Nähe ich habe das ja schon am
Anfang gesagt zwischen der AFD und
diesen diesen diesen
Verschwörungstheoretikern die ist
gegeben und sie bedienen sich auch ein
Stück weit gegenseitig diese verwirrte
wurde ja häufiger gegen die AFD erhoben
gerade auch im Bereich Zusammenhang mit
Corona und Pandemie es wurde ja ein
Abrede gestellt oder bzw behauptet dass
massenweise Menschen gestorben sind
einen Impfung das ließ sich überhaupt
nicht nach ich nehme so ein Beispiel die
sich überhaupt nicht nachweisen anhand
der Statistik des
Instituts ist die AFD da nicht in weit
Stück weit auch selbst schuld an diesem
Image dass man das Gefühl hat dass sie
sich in der Zeit der Zugehörigkeit im
Bundestag seit 2017 immer weiter
radikalisiert hat nein das ist eine
Zuschreibung die nicht korrekt ist und
natürlich weiß auch Herr Fiedler dass es
nicht stimmt was er hier sagt dass die
AFD eine rechtsextreme Kraft sei das
behauptet nicht mal das Bundesamt für
Verfassungsschutz zweitens ist es so
dass die dort vorgenommenen Hinsichten
inwieweit die AFD also ein Verdachtsfall
sei die beruhen darauf dass die AFD eine
restriktive konservative Haltung in
zuwanderungs- und einbürgerungsfragen
vertritt zum Beispiel also
Abstammungsprinzip statt
geburtstagssprinzip meistens
Einbürgerung statt Anspruchs Einwirkung
die Jahrzehnte lang rechtsgültig in
Deutschland waren können von daher nicht
verfassungsfeindlich sein lassen Sie
mich aber auf die eigentliche Frage
zurückkommen was hat in letzter Zeit die
Reichsbürger was hat den den Zulauf
verfasst das war ja der Ausgangspunkt
dieser Frage ja wo dann hier gesagt
wurde das hell Lagern der AFD ich denke
das Gegenteil ist richtig ich glaube
diese Leute meinen gar nicht bitte
reicht das deutsche Kaiserreich davon
wissen die gar nicht sondern dass die
meinen so was ach früher war irgendwie
alles besser und woher kommt das da ist
das Gefühl gegenwärtig wird
das Gefühl was da tatsächlich besteht
ist gegenwärtig wird alles zu schnell
schlechter die Leute sehen dass sie
Inflation durch die Decke geht dass die
Energiepreise durch die Decke gehen dass
die energiesicherung nicht da ist das
nur noch in 100 Milliarden Einheiten
gedacht wird das obwohl wir über 200.000
Zuwanderer haben neben den Ukraine
Leuten weitere pulsignale gesendet
werden Anreize Chancen bleiben recht
erleichterte Einwirkung viele Leute
verzweifeln da und da ist es glaube ich
gerade zu einer Versicherung für das
demokratische System wenn in Gestalt der
AFD innerhalb des parlamentarischen
Systems eine Kraft da ist die den
Bürgern eine Alternative dieser Politik
ermöglicht wenn Sie diese diese
Alternative stellen sie ja nicht
wirklich da die sie immer gerne sein
wollen wenn wir schauen dass
beispielsweise ihre afd-fraktion in
thüringischen Landtag jetzt einen Antrag
einbringt wo man genau diese staatstätte
legitimierer zukünftig vom
Verfassungsschutz nicht mehr beobachten
lassen will wenn man sie gerade zu
schützen will dann zeigt dass diese Nähe
die sie haben und sie stellen sich da
teilweise verteidigen genau für diese
Gruppierung hin und das ist das
politische Spiel dass sie auch immer
wieder betreiben dass sie den Nährboden
schaffen und dass sie die Ideologien die
es in diesen Gruppen offensichtlich gibt
immer wieder auch mit ihren Argumenten
verstärken und das was sie gerade gesagt
haben bestätigt es eigentlich nur ich
muss es nur noch mal klar herausschaffen
weil das gerade gesagt worden ist der
Präsident des Bundesamtes
Verfassungsschutz hat der coole geradezu
ins Gesicht gesagt gestern dass er die
AFD für eine rechtsextreme Partei hält
und das wissen sie auch und haben gerade
das Gegenteil behauptet und sie tun so
als wenn sie legitimer Position oder
Meinungen äußern das Gegenteil ist der
Fall sondern die Zitate die ich gerade
genannt habe die Gegenstand dieses
Gutachtens sind bewegen sich außerhalb
der freiheitlich demokratischen
Grundordnung und sind deswegen
Gegenstand der gerichtlichen Überprüfung
gewesen also auch an dieser Stelle kein
Raum für Relativierung das ist der Grund
dafür warum sie Gerichts überprüft
bundesweit beobachtet werden können von
den Nachrichtendiensten das ist im
Rechtsstaat so entschieden worden und da
gibt es aus meiner Sicht an dieser
Stelle kein Deutsch irgendwie zu
relativieren ich würde das als meine
persönliche Meinungsäußerung auch ganz
klar und eindeutig unterstreichen aus
einem ehemaligen professionellen Blick
heraus der sich aus Sicht der
Kriminalpolizei intensiv mit
extremistischen Strömungen beschäftigt
hat und auch aus diesem Blickwinkel
heraus sage ich ihnen sie sind aus
meiner Sicht unzweifelhaft eine
extremistische Strömung hier in
Deutschland die in den Parlamenten sitzt
und deswegen auch den Rechtsextremismus
in toto so gefährlich macht weil er sich
nämlich unterscheidet von allen anderen
extremistischen Strömung sie versuchen
wie das leider schon mal hier in
Deutschland der Fall war den Rechtsstaat
und die Demokratie von innen heraus
auszuhöhlen und versuchen sie von innen
heraus anzugreifen und sie versuchen
jetzt sozusagen hier das freundliche
Gesicht dieses Rechtsextremismus
darzustellen aber ich habe keinen Anlass
hier ein Stück Relativierung zuzulassen
Thomas Haldenwang hat mit nichten die
AFD als ein rechtsextreme Partei
bezeichnet es gibt eine Frage der
verdachtsfallbeobachtung und es gibt die
Frage des einzelnen Personen oder
Gruppierungen ob die
Bestrebungen nahe stehen die einschlägig
sind da gegen die Freiheitlichen
demokratische Grundordnung das ist eine
Frage der Auseinandersetzung und der
Beobachtung aber natürlich hat das
Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz zu
keinem Zeitpunkt schon gar nicht gestern
Abend die Partei irgendwie als
rechtsextreme bezeichnet gut vielleicht
muss er dann noch sagen dass meines
wissen Sie jetzt aus dem Gedächtnis
zitiert ist den Verdacht
rechtsextremistischer Beschreibung in
drei Bundesländer gibt in Thüringen in
die in Brandenburg in Sachsen und
Sachsen-Anhalt und gesicherte
rechtsextremistische Bestrebungen im
Landesverband ihrer Partei in Thüringen
das ist
was die landesverhörungsschutzämter da
inzwischen veröffentlicht habe oder
beschlossen haben
ich möchte auch noch auf eine Äußerung
von ihnen reagieren ich finde es ehrlich
gesagt in Farben wenn sie sagen also mit
dem Vorwurf des
verfassungsfeindlichen konfrontiert
werden und dann sagen die AFD sei nur
eine restriktive konservative Kraft und
dann zählen Sie eine Reihe von
politischen Debatten Punkten auf bei
denen man in dieser oder jener Meinung
sei in sein kann und die sich natürlich
die man natürlich auch in der Breite im
demokratischen Spektrum diskutieren kann
und das ist mit nichten so dass die AFD
an den Punkten als verfassungsfeindlich
bezeichnet wird an denen sie gegen die
doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft ist das ist
ja etwas gegen die Union in Teilen auch
ist sondern es geht ja wirklich darum
dass sie das Gift sowohl in den
politischen Betrieb wie auch in die
Gesellschaft ein Teufeln lassen und die
Menschen die politisch unzufrieden sind
abholen und gegen den Staat aufhetzen da
geht es dann eben nicht mehr darum dass
über die Inhalte diskutiert wird sondern
wird der Staat insgesamt in Frage
gestellt durch Geraune und eben
delegitimiert und desavouiert und dort
wo man konstruktiv eine politische
Debatte führt ist überhaupt nichts
dagegen einzuwenden eine restriktive
konservative Haltung zu haben und da
würden sie wenn sie das täten würden sie
auch einen bestimmten politischen
Bereich in diesem Land abdecken aber sie
tun es nur zum Schein und holen Leute ab
und versammeln Menschen hinter sich um
diese gegen das Land aufzuhetzen und das
ist übrigens auch das Gegenteil von
patriotisch sein weil sie die AFD ja
gerne auf die Fahnen schreibt wenn
jemand behauptet irgendetwas würde nur
zum Schein geschehen ist der
unterstellungs Charakter schon
offensichtlich und natürlich man hört es
schon an den bei der Begrifflichkeit ist
in diesen
verdachtsdokumenten auch nicht von
einträufeln in dem Gift die Rede und
auch nicht davon dass der Staat
untergraben wird sondern es geht da um
den Begriff der Volkszugehörigkeit und
das hat etwas zu tun mit der reformenden
Staatsbürgerschaftsrechts die ist
gegeben hat da gab es früher ein anderes
Recht was abstammungsorientiert war und
ermessenseinbürgerung dann gab es ein
geburtsortsprinzip und eine
anspruchseinwirkung in dieser Differenz
bewegt sich das Spezifikum der
afd-position in dieser ganzen Frage
Zugehörigkeit Staatsbürgerschaft darum
geht es und es geht nicht darum das
behauptet auch nicht mal dass unsere
Verfassungsschutz irgendwie dass der
Staat damit ich würde ganz gerne zu dem
Thema unserer Sendung zurückkehren
nämlich zu den Razzien unter den
reichsbürgern und auch dem
untertitelwiderstand sich wehren soll
und wie er sich wehren muss Atom es sind
die eine ganze Reihe von Bediensteten
öffentlich Bediensteten bei Verdacht
gewesen einige sind ja verhaftet worden
Beamte mit verfassungsfreundliche
Gesinnung soll die künftig das hat auch
die Bundesministerin gesagt künftig
schneller aus dem Staatsdienst entlassen
werden wo liegen denn eigentlich die
rechtlichen Hindernisse wenn man eine
verfassungsfeindliche ges Bock hat dass
man es gibt ja da oft Verfahren die sich
über Jahre hinziehen die gehen vor die
Arbeitsgericht ich glaube in jedem
Bundesland in Baden-Württemberg
entscheidet dass die Exekutive auf
Bundesebene geht es direkt an die
Gerichte wo liegen da die
Schwierigkeiten mit Verfassungsfeinden
entsprechend umzugehen um sie dann aus
dem Staatsdienst wenn sie erwiesen
verfassungsfeindlich sind dann auch zu
entlassen also ganz klar ist wer nicht
auf unserer freiheitlich demokratischen
Grundordnung steht der hat den
Staatsdienst nichts zu suchen und muss
dann im Zweifel auch entlassen werden
jetzt hat die Innenministerin in einer
regierungsbefragung von einer
Beweislastumkehr gesprochen also in
Zukunft müssten bei Verdachtsfällen die
Betroffenen sich entlastend beweisen
dass es eben nicht so ist das hat sie
jetzt im vergangenen Sonntag in einer
Fernsehsendung wieder eingeholt und hat
gesagt das würde nicht gehen in der Tat
weil das wäre grob verfassungswidrig wir
haben ein
Berufsbeamtentum und das ist auch etwas
Besonderes deswegen können wir auch
diese
Platz Treue und diese Rechtstreue eben
entsprechend einfordern und was ist
jetzt geht und es hat auch nichts mit
einer Verschärfung zu tun auch da wird
es glaube ich von der Innenministerin
weitergehen der dargestellt als es
tatsächlich ist es geht um die Frage ob
der Staat vor Gericht gehen muss in
einer sogenannten disziplinar-lage und
den Beamten aus dem Staatsdienst
herausgeladen muss oder ob der Staat per
Verwaltungsakt dieses verfügen kann und
dann der Betroffene oder die Betroffene
sich dagegen ebenfalls vor dem
Verwaltungsgericht wären muss ich kann
nicht erkennen dass damit irgendeine
Beschleunigung damit verbunden wäre es
sei denn der Betroffene klagt selbst
nicht was in der Regel nicht zu erwarten
sein wird und dann dauert das Verfahren
ganz genauso wie umgekehrt aber beide
sind durchaus recht stattlich dankbare
Wege in Baden-Württemberg wird es anders
gemacht wie jetzt im Bund darüber kann
man diskutieren nur eine Beschleunigung
eine Verschärfung ist mit den
Vorschlägen die jetzt auf dem Tisch
liegen damit es zu solchen rechtlichen
Auseinandersetzung erst gar nicht kommt
der Fiedler sie haben ja vor ihrer Zeit
als Bundestagsabgeordneter auch eine
berufliche Karriere in einem
sicherheitsrelevanten Bereich nämlich
bei der Kriminalpolizei hinter sich die
waren ja auch Vorsitzender des
bundesdeutsche Kriminal Beamter
ist es dann oder wäre es einfacher eine
solche Sicherheitsüberprüfung vor der
Einstellung schon vorzunehmen und nicht
erst während der Tätigkeit in einem
sicherheitsempfindlichen Bereich zu
merken durch Äußerungen durch
persönliches Verhalten Vorsicht da ist
jemand der möglicherweise eine
Schlagseite hat wird dazu wenig vor der
Einstellung geguckt wer da eigentlich
eingestellt wird das gelten sowohl als
auch und das passiert der teilweise beim
bundeskriminal dann zum Beispiel
passiert das genauso wie sie das gerade
fordern aber es war passiert eben nicht
vielleicht entdecken und auch nicht in
allen Bundesländern und deswegen wird es
darauf ankommen jetzt sozusagen ein
Bündel von unterschiedlichen Maßnahmen
noch mal herzustellen um die Situation
dann noch mal zu verbessern also der
eine Punkt den hatte schon Wert ich
glaube durchaus allerdings dass das
baden-württembergemodell geeignet ist um
eine Beschleunigung des Verfahrens
hinzukriegen das würde ich schon meinen
weil es geht eigentlich nicht so sehr um
die Frage rechtsstaatlicher Grundsätze
dass dem stimme ich zu es geht
allerdings darum dass jemand schneller
aus de facto aus dem Dienst herauskommt
ohne das sozusagen recht staatlich etwas
unterminiert wird also das ist glaube
ich schon relevanter Punkt das ist der
zweite also an welchen Stellen gucken
frühzeitig auch die Nachrichtendienste
auf künftige also auf Bewerber schon im
Vorwege und es gibt aber auch noch
weitere Maßnahmen wir sind jetzt in
dieser Woche gerade dabei das
Hinweisgeber Schutzgesetz abzuschließen
da haben wir auch noch mal einen
wichtigen wichtiges Augenmerk genau auf
diesen Punkt gesetzt das heißt Leute die
und das haben wir ja häufiger gehabt bei
chatgruppen und ähnlichen Situationen
haben wir immer Situation gehabt dass
dort Mitarbeiter
Polizeibeamte auch in den Gruppen dabei
waren die sich nicht aktiv beteiligt
haben und die sollen ermutigt werden
tatsächlich dann auch eine Meldung zu
machen über einen solchen Sachverhalt
dazu dient dieses Gesetz wir haben
weiterhin noch in der Beratung und dem
Koalitionsvertrag verankert wir werden
eine Stelle eines polizeibeauftragten
einer polizeibeauftragten auf
Bundesebene machen um das auch zu
unterstützen wie wir das von der
werbeauftragten kennen aber es gibt
durchaus eine ganze Bandbreite von
unterschiedlichen Maßnahmen mit denen
wir die Situation noch verbessern können
das soll aber nicht darüber
hinwegtäuschen dass wir sozusagen diesen
einen Punkt noch im Blick haben müssen
der Staat war hier erfolgreich also das
muss schon durchaus noch mal sagen und
das hat die erfolgreich auch
funktioniert das gegen Polizeibeamte und
gegen Soldaten und Soldaten ermittelt
werden konnte das darf man jetzt
insoweit nicht vergessen dass das dieses
Verfahren ist ein belegt dafür dass der
Staat hier sehr gut funktioniert hat in
diesem Fall oder der Staat halt nicht
gut funktioniert und wo es
Handlungsbedarf gibt das haben sie ja
gerade beschrieben ist wenn es darum
geht staatsfeindliche Beamte aus dem
Dienst zu entfernen und es geht nicht um
Beamte es geht ja auch um Soldaten also
auch im Verteidigungsministerium ist ja
als Reaktion auf diese Razzia und die
neuen Erkenntnisse ein Gesetz in der
Pipeline was die vorherige
Verteidigungsministerin Frau
Kramp-Karrenbauer schon mal versucht
hatte anzuschieben nämlich dass man auch
Soldaten und auch Zeitsoldaten nach
einem längeren Zeitraum wenn sie als
Staatsfeinde identifiziert sind noch aus
dem Dienst entfernen kann und man hatte
ja versucht die Richterin mal sagt
Winkelmann hatten die bellen Berliner
versucht dass sie nicht weiter das
Richterinnen
als Richterin arbeiten kann und das ist
den Behörden eben nicht gelungen und da
ist ganz klar Handlungsbedarf und das
auch schnell Handlungsbedarf Bundeswehr
noch ganz kurz da gab es ja immer wieder
auch Fälle man weiß es nicht genau ist
das eine Struktur sind das Einzelfälle
da gibt es unterschiedliche Sichtweisen
darauf lag das bei der Bundeswehr auch
daran dass man nach der Abschaffung oder
nach der Aussetzung der Wehrpflicht
einfach viele Leute gesucht hat für die
ganzen Aufgaben und dass man da etwas
oberflächlich war was möglicherweise da
rekrutiert und angeworben wird diese
problematischen Strukturen insbesondere
bei der Pascal die haben sich ja schon
viel früher gebildet deshalb gehe ich
nicht davon aus dass das unbedingt in
der Zeitgeschehen ist es mag sein dass
Menschen die zu Bundeswehr gehen
vielleicht
etwas anfälliger dafür sind auf eine
bestimmte Art und Weise
sich zu radikalisieren weil sie
natürlich als Vertreter von
Ordnungsbehörden das muss man eben auch
sagen Soldaten und Polizisten sehen was
auch für Missstände in der Gesellschaft
sind und da dann möglicherweise zu
falschen Schlüssen kommen können was für
Konsequenzen man daraus ziehen muss um
den Staat aus ihrer Sicht vor anderen
Straftaten wiederum zu schützen aber ich
sehe nicht unbedingt dass das jetzt was
mit der freiwilligen Armee zu tun hat
und bei der KSK Mann ist ja auch schon
man ist ja bei der KSK schon ganze Stück
vorangekommen also die sind ja schon in
einem Prozess um eben sich davor zu
schützen das weiterhin solche Feinde in
ihrem eigenen Pelz sitzen
jetzt gerade schon gefallen die frühere
traktionskollegin von ihr die jetzt zu
den Festgenommenen
zählt jetzt habe ich heute gehört dass
die AFD beim
Generalbundesanwalt Akteneinsicht
beantragt haben soll um ein Partei
Ordnungsverfahren mit den möglichen
Ausschnitt einzuleiten sie ist ja auch
noch Mitglied im Bundesschiedsgericht
als Beisitzerin ist ja auch keine
wichtige unwichtige Institution
innerhalb einer Partei wie beurteilen
sie denn eigentlich die Person das was
mit ihr gerade geschieht und wie muss
die AFD jetzt darauf reagieren ich habe
gerade schon gesagt man verhaftet nicht
irgendwie jemanden ohne Grund und wenn
jemand in uhaft kommt ist die
Wahrscheinlichkeit hoch dass man im
Hauptverfahren dann auch tatsächlich
verurteilt wird
Akteneinsicht zu verstehe ich es nicht
um jemanden auszuschließen sondern um
erstmal Kenntnisse zu erreichen was hier
tatsächlich vorliegt und deshalb finde
ich auch die Formulierung die gerade
vorher getroffen wurde man hat versucht
sie der Berliner Senat auszuschließen
von ihrem Richteramt und es ist nicht
gelungen also besteht Handlungsbedarf
finde ich doch ein bisschen seltsam also
das scheint eine geringes Vertrauen in
die deutsche Justiz davor zu liegen denn
es ist einfach so dass selbst nach denen
ja höheren Maß den schärferen Maßstäben
Stichwort mäßigungsgebot für Beamte an
freie Meinungsäußerungen tatsächlich der
Abgeordneten nicht nur bei ihren paar
reden innerhalb des Parlaments die
besonderen Schutz der freien Rede
genießen sondern auch außerhalb Tweets
und so etwas gerade nicht nachgewiesen
werden konnte dass irgendetwas besteht
was von ihrer einer etwaigen radikalen
Gesinnung Zeugen würde dass der dann
besteht erstmal kein Handlungsbedarf
jemand das darf man ruhig erstmal wenn
ein Gericht das so bewertet zur Kenntnis
nehmen und vor diesem Hintergrund ist es
in der Tat sie haben völlig recht wo
jetzt diese neuerliche
anschuldigungslage da ist ist es glaube
ich die Partei
gut beraten und sehr verständlich dass
sie aufgeklärt werden
weniger radikal als zum Beispiel Jens
Meier auch ein ehemaliger Kollege aus
dem Bundestag den ich wieder gewählt
worden ist und der in Sachsen eben sein
Richteramt nicht mehr antreten konnte
und in den Ruhestand versetzt worden ist
also ich vermag diese Unterscheidung
jetzt so
nicht zu treffen sie müssen immer sehen
es gibt die Tätigkeit von
Parteikollegen innerhalb der Fraktion
und dann sind das aber auch alles noch
mal ähm Politiker in ihren eigenen
Landesverbänden und was ich jetzt
beurteilen kann ist eben die Performance
in der Fraktion und auch in Berliner
Landesverband die Tätigkeit von normal
sag Winkelmann und da ist also
herausgekommen bei der gerichtlichen
Würdigung dass ihr nichts vorzuwerfen
ist aber wie sich ist das mit dem
sächsischen ex-abgeordneten verhält
vermag ich jetzt von hier aus nicht ad
hoc zu sagen da waren die Behörden ja
durchaus unterschiedlicher Meinung über
Frau mahlsackwinkelmann und wenn die
Behörden nur in der Lage sind die Spitze
des Eisbergs zu sehen dann heißt das
nicht dass kein Handlungsbedarf besteht
es ist gut dass der Rechtsstaat auch
Leute schützt
unrechtmäßig aus Ämtern entfernt zu
werden und das muss der Rechtsstaat auch
weiterhin tun und auch wenn wir wenn es
dort eine zu einer Gesetzesverschärfung
kommt dann wird man aufpassen müssen
dass niemand zu Unrecht aus dem Dienst
entlassen wird aber bei Frau mal sagt
Winkelmann ist das ganz offensichtlich
ein Fall von einer Person die sich
radikalisiert hat und nicht obwohl es
einige gab die diese Gefahr gesehen
haben nicht aus dem Staat jetzt entfernt
werden konnte das Gericht hat diese
Gefahr offensichtlich nicht gesehen und
inwieweit
gesehen haben
die juristische Würdigung hat das
Ergebnis
wird jetzt neue belegbare zurechenbare
Vorwürfe tatsächlich vorbringbar sind
genau das will die Partei erfahren und
dann schon was will die Partei erfahren
sehen Sie und das ist immer der Punkt wo
ich so ein bisschen aus der Haut weil
sie haben eine in einem anderen
Interview ernsthaft gesagt es handelt
sich nur um eine Zuschreibung zu Frau
Mann sagt wenn es sein nur Zuschreibung
noch mal hier handelt es sich um ein
länger betriebenes Ermittlungsverfahren
hier sind tausende von seitenakten
beschrieben worden es hat
Gerichtsbeschlüsse gegeben das
entscheidet nicht der
Generalbundesanwalt alleine und noch mal
sie haben es jetzt ja auch schon
mehrfach gesagt der Bundesgerichtshof
der Ermittlungsrichter hat gesagt okay
das stimmt alles so das heißt wir reden
über jemanden wo der dringende
Terrorverdacht besteht und dann geht's
nicht um bloße Zuschreibung sondern es
geht darum dass zumindest der BGA zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt sagt das ist mit
hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit ein Mitglied
einer terroristischen Vereinigung da
könnte man vielleicht diese
relativierenden Vokabeln ein bisschen
vom Tisch nehmen
darf wir haben gerade
berichtet dass eben zum Beispiel dieses
narrativ Eindringen in den Bundestag
gerade nicht bestätigt wurde und es ist
auch tatsächlich so bislang wurde immer
nur eine gesamterzählung vorgedacht darf
ich darf ich mal aus darf ich ausführen
Untersuchungsrichter wurde gestern vom
Generalbundesanwalt der dort berichtet
hat hat genau diesen Punkt nicht mit
außer Frage aber wenn ich zu Ende
ausführen darf nur ganz kurz
bislang haben wir von einem
gesamtzählung gehört und was jetzt
tatsächlich innerhalb einer größeren
Gruppe einzelnen Personen zurechenbar
ist vorwerfbar ist das bleibt jetzt zu
untersuchen und da in diesem wenn nicht
nur den Satz zu Ende führen darf da habe
ich lediglich gesagt wenn Leute sagen ja
die ist Juristen schreibt die mal auf
Justiz damit ist noch gar nichts gesagt
dass sie sich irgendwie zu irgendetwas
bekannt hat oder irgendwelche Handlungen
vorbereiten
Masche dass sie erst dann wenn es nicht
mehr bestreitbar ist wenn wenn
Haftbefehl vorliegt sie dann als Partei
hingehen sagen die schließen wir jetzt
aus da haben wir schon eine Vielzahl
eine Vielzahl von beispielswellen was es
sonst in anderen Parteien nicht gibt da
wollen sie dann ihre parteimit schützen
aber gleichzeitig im selben im selben
Atemzug relativieren sie verharmlosen
sie doch verharmlosen sie die Vorhaben
die Tatsachen es hat ja noch gar nicht
stattgefunden nach ihrer Wort hätte man
hätte man warten hätte man warten sollen
bis etwas passiert das soll man gerade
nicht tun das Vorhaben die Zielsetzung
die Ideologie ist jetzt hier ganz
eindeutig zum Ausdruck gekommen und sie
bestätigen mit ihren Ausführungen im
Grunde genommen dass die AFD sich hier
auch verteidigen vor derartigen
Gruppierungen hinstellt
Untersuchungsrichter hat diesen Punkt
nicht bestätigen wollen aber wie absurd
ist die Vorstellung dass sie innerhalb
dieser Verschwörer als mögliche
Justizministerin ja nach einem Umsturz
gehandelt wird und eine so selbst ich
wusste Frau das einfach mit sich machen
lässt ohne dass sie sagt ja ich kann mir
vorstellen in so einem Team mitzuwirken
ja also das ist doch wirklich absurd und
das ist doch sehr offensichtlich erst
davor liegt an wirklich
zurechenbaren vor das habe ich ja vorhin
schon prognostiziert dass der
generalbundesamt weil viel Arbeit haben
wird und später die Gerichte das wird
sich Jahre hinsichtlich würde gern ein
Aspekt noch erproben wir haben nur noch
zwei Minuten aber ein Aspekt der auch
einen etwas ratlos zurücklässt wir haben
1500 mutmaßliche rechts Terroristen
Rechtsextremisten in diesem landschulung
Rechtsextremisten mutmaßliche über eine
Waffen Erlaubnis verfügen eigentlich
nach dem bestehenden Waffengesetz ist
schon das ja ein Ding da gehört auch die
charakterliche Eignung zum Führen einer
Waffe dazu wie kann das sein das ist ja
jetzt auch im Zusammenhang mit der
Razzia noch mal erörtert worden ja also
wir haben ein verschärftes Waffen
gesetzt das in der letzten Periode unter
Unionsführung erlassen wurde wo genau
die Mitgliedschaft oder die
Anhängerschaft auch zu extremistischen
Gruppierungen oder Gedankengut ein
Ausschlussgrund sind in der Regel um
eine Waffenbesitzkarte nicht zu erhalten
oder wenn sie vorhanden ist zu entziehen
und was auch eine Neuerung ist wir haben
eine Regel Anfrage jetzt im beim
Verfassungsschutz wenn eine
Waffenbesitzkarte beantragt oder
verlängert wird und insofern ist ganz
klar wer es derartigen Gruppierung
angehört nahe steht darf keine Waffe
keine Frage
1500 mutmaßlich Rechtsextremisten mit
Waffen muss das Waffenrecht werden
es sollte auch schon mal rangegangen
werden der Thomas unterschlagen dass
selbst Horst Seehofer sich darüber
geklagt hat dass er nicht mehr zum Ende
der Legislatur dann noch mal ran konnte
weil die Lobby Aktivitäten so unfassbar
aggressiv gewesen sind dass deswegen
nichts mehr passiert ist und ich rate
uns dazu jetzt kritisch noch mal hin zu
gucken an welchen Stellen wir wirklich
noch mal Nachschärfen müssen da gibt's
nämlich noch ein paar Stellschrauben
Koalitionspartner
ähm das Thema ist im Fluss wie so vieles
ich bedanke mich hier in der Phönix
Runde dabei ich war Quadbeck bei
Sebastian Siedler bei kurio und bei
Alexander throm Liebe ZuschauerInnen
liebe Zuschauer morgen der Phönix Runde
Ukraine Krieg im Winter was kann der
Westen tun
aktuelles und weiteres bei Phoenix der
Tag mit Maya Weber darin
aktuelles zum Korruptions Skandal im
Europäischen Parlament auch ein großes
Aufregerthema in dieser Woche bleiben
Sie bei uns
[Musik]